un pe comme une B
[Musique]
num
le 1er novembre 1970 il est 2h30 un
important incendie s'est déclaré dans un
établissement de nuit dis le 57 tragédie
dans l'Isère aux premières heures de
cette journée de la toussin plus de 140
morts dans un incendie ils étaient allés
danser c'était des jeunes en grande
majorité ils étaient allés au 57 situé à
voir près du village de saintlaur d fin
des années 60 les enfants du baby boom
sont en âge de sortir l'époque est à la
musique et à l'insouciance et l'incendie
du 57 vient tragiquement ternir la
fête ce drame n'aurait pourtant jamais
dû se produire avec le recul les
manquements élémentaires à la sécurité
du 57 paraissent
inexcusable aujourd'hui on voit mal
comment un incendie d'une t ampleur pour
dans un établissement au
norm les 146 enfants du 57 sont le prix
insensé de l'insoucience de
l'époque quand nous sommes arrivés les
premiers qui sont venus vers nous
notamment le chef de centre nous a dit
il y a plus rien à faire le pompier il
y une dizaine de véhicules qui étaient
tout autour à notre grand étonnement
pas de bruit un
silence on entendait pas d'ordre donné
on entendait pas d'établissement de
lance et
ca sa
ppier c'est une personne qui ve
sauver par de
mort et quand onous bah il y a plus
personne à sauver ça ça a été très dur
quoi alors le monument a été érigé sur
l'emplacement même de bon le bâtiment
était
[Musique]
là plus é de va avoir 26 ans 26 ans 27
an
eur des secours le capitaine des saeurs
Pompi a été obligé de forer ét ferm
c'estblissement mé mais il y peut-être
aussi un peu trop de matière plastique
dans
ceétaementès vite la questione des
matériaux trop inflammabl qui ont été
utilisés pour construire
[Musique]
lever de
plastique on les a mis dans une voiture
à l'hôpital pendant une semaine la
France est le plastique et le
polystyrène utilisé pour sculpter
facilement le décor de la boîte de nuit
sont hautement inflammables l'incendie
se propage rapidement dans tout
l'établissement des gouttelett enflammé
tomb du plafond en polystyrène et rien
ne peut arrêter le
feu estti du prier étage audessus du bar
dans le coin d'une loge en la tête moi
j'ai vu comme une
une une traînée jaunâtre le rescapé le
réflexe a été
de de sauter par-dessus le le bar et de
crier qu'il y avait le le feu et ben de
me diriger avec vers une sortie de
secours et donc d'entraîner avec moi je
sais plus combien il y avait peut-être
une une quinzaine de personnes qui nous
ont qui nous ont suivi samedi j'ai vu
des gens courir alors je croyais qu'il y
avait quelque chose dehors al je suis
allé voir et puis j'ai vu des flammes
sortir bienentrée vous avez franchi le
tourniquier de la porte d'entrée
oui sans difficulté
non là je suis passé la première alors
un Tourquet beaucoup de jeunes sont
restés bloqués au niveau du tourniquet
qui avait été installé à l'entrée pour
contrôler les passages et éviter la
resquille et beaucoup d'autres se sont
heur à des issues de secours condamné
c'est très
en fait de secours était fermé et vous
AZ obigé de les
forcer harcelé par la presse le gérant
survivant
assume bon vous avez C portes si on
laisse C portes ouvertes c'est même plus
la peine de faire payer des entrées ça
tout le monde le comprend bien
ça on retrouvé des issues bloquées une
issue de secours ou une
issue qui qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
fermé et qui permet la la pénétration
euh librement c'est une issue qui fait
perdre de l'argent mais c'est dur ce que
je dis là mais il faut
[Musique]
faut les trois jeunes gérants du 57
étaient originaires du village de
Saint-Laurent du pont deux d'entre eux
ont péri dans
[Musique]
l'incendie je connaissais ceux qui on
monté cette affaire si on peut dire le
maire qui donnait un certain dynamisme
qui était un petit peu exceptionnel pour
un village qui n'avait que 3500
habitants était connu ils étaient au
milieu de la population et très
dynamique au point de vue musique par
les orchestres qui faisaient venir et
puis la dynamique qui mettait autour des
villes en mettant par exemple des
services de carte sur Chambéry ou
Grenoble bien très vite ils ont connu un
succès assez
important il beaucoup de
monde l'établissement était était réputé
il y en avait deux trois comme ça sur
autour de Grenoble l'enfant du pays
c'est le début des boîtes de nuit en
région rurale à l'époque les gens
allaient au bal avant il allai au bal il
un orchestre plus ou moins bon il
buvaient du blanc limé du rouge limé
voilà c'était terminé puis après il y a
eues boîtes de
nuit Patrice Morel est un journaliste
qui qui connaissait bien le 57 il a
perdu des amis dans la
catastrophe en fait on devait y aller ce
soirlà et on y est pas allé parce qu'on
avait pas assez d'argent mes parents
m'avaient pas donné assez de pogon à
l'époque du coup on est allé dans une
une surprise parti de l'époque chez des
potes et c'est c'est le lendemain matin
je suis rentré à 3 4h du Matth ma mère
m'a pas m'a pas entendu rentrer et à à
8h le matin cétait une furie qui qui qui
saute dans ma chambre c'était ma mère je
me souviens toujours vous êtes là
et elle avait entendu à la radio le le
truc et elle nous avait pas entendu
rentrer mon frère allait souvent au 57
elle a dit [__] ils y sont allés quoi
et je pense que dans beaucoup de
familles dans la région ronalp ça été
comme ça la même scène le matin c'était
un truc
incroyable ce qui était le plus marquant
c'était le gymnase où ils avaient mis
les 140 circueils
[Musique]
le drame frappe particulièrement les
esprits parce que les victimes sont très
nombreuses très jeunes et qu'elles sont
décédées alors qu'elles étaient venues
pour l'amour de la musique et de la fête
comme si la jeunesse payait le prix des
libertés acquises 2 ans auparavant en
1968 le magazine arakiri dénonça sa
façon l'emballement
médiatique
le traitement a été le traitement d'une
catastrophe hors norme mondiale tout de
suite ça c'était la une du dauphinet le
lendemain matin ça c'est un collègue de
FR3 de Grenoble aujourd'hui c'est
impossible de faire ça aujourd'hui scène
de crime là les premiers journalistes
jusqu'à au milieu de matinée rien les
empêcha de rentrer
quoi ilent pas de main mort quand
mêmein les les les journalistes de la
presse à sensation qui s'en sont apparés
un petit peu après mais comme de GA est
mort dans la foulée ça éclips tout ça
quoi de GA c'était un autre morceau
voilà et on a oublié les 142
jeunes c'est pour ça que harakir a tié
bal tragique à
Colombis le 16 novembre c'est la
couverture de TR àakiri est interdit le
journal satirique renêtra immédiatement
sous le nom de Charlie Hebdo
il y a toujours le drame qui reste gravé
dans la mémoire mais on pense aussi à la
jeunesse qui est plus la même et qui a
des besoins des désir aussi de
disons d'avoir des salles similaires la
population est pas prête à disons à
retrouver à Saint-Laurent DUP pont ce
qui s'est passé avant parce que c'est
trop lourd por porter et
finalement on va jamais dans ce sens
quoi c'est un mélange entre la jeunesse
qui veut vivre et puis le souvenir de
celle qui a été victime de cette
catastrophe il n'y a plus de dansigne à
Saint-Laurent du pont et il n en aura
pas avant longtemps mais 2000 boîtes de
nuit sont réparties sur le territoire
français et aujourd'hui le risque
incendie est pris très au sérieux dans
ces établissements à de de triomp Le
Duplex célèbre club parisien est en
plein travaux et l'architect responsable
du chantier doit intégrer beaucoup
d'éléments relatifs à la sécurité nous
sommes 45 ans après le 57 l'époque est
celle du principe de précaution il y a
de éléments très importants à prendre en
compte la première c'est comment on
évacue les personnes et on les sécurise
et la deè c'est en cas d'incendie
comment on évacue la fumée comment on
éteintc l'architecte dans celui-ci on
tient compte de la quantité que l'espace
peut accueillir de personnes et on
dimensionne le nombre d'issus de secours
en proportion de cela sachant que toutes
les portes qui sont mises en place sont
des portes bien sû coupefeu c'est c'est
comme si cette salle qui a une
configuration presque rectangulaire on a
quatre évacuations aux quatre angles
donc dans la logique d'évacuation une
personne qui se retrouve quel que soit
l'endroit où elle se retrouve elle a à
proximité la possibilité
[Applaudissements]
d'échapper deuxème élément bien sûr le
désenfumage
le principe d'un désenfumage il est pour
la globalité de l'espace s'il y a un
problème de main la globalité se mettra
en marche pour queil y ait rien de
laissé au hasard et que toute la fumée
ensuite sera aspirée avec un débit d'ire
extrêmement puissant la troisème chose
c'est bien sûr le réseau de sprinklage
dans tout établissement recevant du
public ce qu'on appelle les ERP à partir
d'une certaine catégorie on met en place
un réseau d'eau en plafond avec des
petites têtes qui ressortent du faux
plafond on a des distances à respecter
entre elles pour couvrir la globalité de
l'espace et si demain il y a un incendie
les têtes avec la montée en température
fonde et et ça permet de balancer de
l'eau d'une manière
uniforme et puis après on a les fameux
matériaux donc chaque chaque société qui
sort ou qui fabrique un matériau que ce
soit un matériau tissu par exemple ou un
matériau résine doit passer par une
classification donc il y a plein de
tests à faire de résistance au feu de
sorte qu'on leur délivre ce PV de
classement qui permet aux architectes de
dire bah nous on a utilisé les matériaux
correspondants à la
me ces matériaux ont des traitements de
sorte que en cas de d'incendie il n'y
ait pas de dégagement de fumée toxique
pendant un certain temps après tout
matériau dans un cadre d'incendie de
toute façon brûlera il faut juste que ça
soit retardé le plus
possible grâce à la prise en compte de
toutes ces normes un drame comme celui
du 57 ne pourrait pas se reproduire
aujourd'hui dans un établissement
conforme la réglementation ne concerne
pas seulement les boîtes de nuit tous
les établissements recevants du public
doivent respecter des normes de
construction et d'exploitation strictes
les salles de concerts les cinémas les
théâtres ou encore les grands immeubles
les grandes
surfaces en 2014 seulement 5 personnes
sont décédées dans des établissements
recevants du public quelles étaient donc
les normes à l'époque du
57 le major Roland est spécialiste de
l'histoire de la sécurité incendie
[Musique]
en 1970 on connaissait tout ça je veux
dire tout est en place le pompier
historien ce que je vous présente c'est
le règlement de
l'époque l'arrêté de 1965 qui est en
vigueur à l'époque du drame et qui
contre toute attente et bien comporte
toutes les recommandations ou toutes les
précisions techniques ou réglementaires
qui auraent dû éviter ce drame
dans la réglementation les dancings sont
classés dans les établissements du type
P on a des choses très précises avec des
tableaux avec des schémas donc il y a
vraiment une volonté de rendre le plus
clair possible cette réglementation la
plus exploitable possible vous avez
toute la partie technique qu'est-ce
qu'un feu quels sont les les critères de
réaction au feu de de différents
matériaux qu'on peut ou qu'on ne peut
pas employer dans les constructions qui
reçoivent du public et là forcé de
constater d'ailleurs c'est une c'est un
des points fort un des points d'ancrage
de la prévention c'est l'étude de la
réaction des matériaux on a déjà des
structures qui s'intéressent justement à
aux effets des fumées et de tous ces
produits toxiques qui émanent de
l'incendie on voit très bien que le
polystyrène fond qui produit des gouttes
enflammées et qui ne s'éteint pas
spontanément donc on sait que mis au
plafond et bien c'est une pluie de feu
qui va tomber c'est ce qui s'est passé
le le jour du drame dans le cas du 57 on
a accumuler à peu près tous les dangers
qu'on pouvait attirer dans ce type
d'établissement le chauffage n'est pas
conforme l'installation électrique on
s'interroge le le cumul de matériaux
hautement inflammable et dangereux
asphixiant et puis dans le registre de
la pratique on a bien des sorties
d'issus de secours parce qu'elles sont
préconisées mais elles sont verrouillées
pour des raisons
d'exploitation le drame dans le drame
c'est que la réglementation de l'époque
si elle avait été respectée aurait
permis d'éviter la
catastrophe mais le risque était alors
mal appréhendé et par ailleurs certains
pensent que l'on a fermé les yeux car la
de nuit donn du dynamisme au petit
village de montagne en 1970 André Verret
travaillait au Dauphiné Libéré tout le
monde savait que le 57 était ouvert ça
arrangeait tout le monde la presse
locale tout le monde dans le pays sait
que le 57 c'est asse c'estes trois
jeunes et que ça va quand ça ouvre tout
le monde le sait il y a pas encore les
autorisation ils ouvrent alors que les
autorisations d'ouvrir sont pas encore
arrivées mais je crois que franchement
ça doit se faire assez couramment et
puis après c'est régularisé le temps que
que toutes C cette procédure
administrative aboutissent il y a pas de
problème mais voilà il y a 142 146 morts
alors forcément faut faire quelque
chosees donc on poursuit le maire on
poursuit le secrétaire général de la
préfecture pas le préfet bizarrement
mais le secrétaire général de la
préfecture pe pas poursuivre les gérants
qui sont morts donc il y a celui qui est
rescapé ben on va ULP et puis bah on
poursuit le gars du chauffage quoi parce
que le chauffage il s'avère que il est
pas vraiment installé dans les règles et
d'abord le jugement du tribunal de Lyon
il a condamné les CIN responsables de la
tragédie du 57 de Saint-Laurent Dupont a
des peines de prison avec surcis simple
autrement dit les cinq inculpés sont
libres ce
soir 2 ans de prison avec surc pour
gilbertba les installateurs du chauffage
condamnés à 15 et 13 mois de prison avec
surc Albert Moskovitz le PDG de la
société Chebi fournisseur de la matière
plastique de décoration est condamné à
10 mois de prison avec surcis la même
peine pour Pierre Perin le maire de
Saint-Laurent DUP il y a pas eu de
prison ferme rien
aujourd'hui cet événement se passe
ici dans l'iser par exemple vous avez
142 morts avec les conditions de
d'insécurité qui était à l'intérieur du
du bâtiment aujourd'hui d'abord le
préfet il saute euh
le il peutv même faire de la TLE
aujourd'hui mais à l'époque il y avait
pas la rigueur d'aujourd'hui c'était une
époque d'insouciance parce que c'était
les 30 glorieuses
euh il y avait pas de chômage il y avait
pas de sida les gens allit en boîte
draguait on avait 18 ans c'était la vie
qui s'ouvrait il y avait pas de ceinture
de sécurité les gens rentrait il roulit
bourré des fois j'ai j'ai quand même pas
mal de de copains d'enfance qui sont
morts sur la route les nombres
d'accidents sur sur la route c'était
incroyable mais il y avait pas c'était
de l'insouciance peut-être de
l'irresponsabilité aujourd'hui on dirait
de l'irresponsabilité à l'époque non ça
faisait partie des années
60 la catastrophe du 57 est
symptommatique d'une époque celle qui a
précédé la société du risque et
justement ce sont des drames comme celui
du 57 qui ont fait bouger les lignes qui
ont changé les mentalités en profondeur
aujourd'hui les normes de sécurité ne
sont plus prises à la légère le retour
d'expérience de ce type d'accident et
bien c'est de mieux maîtriser la chaîne
administrative du contrôle les permis de
construire et puis du contrôle sur place
entre la conformité de ce que l'on a
déposé comme projet et de ce qui s'est
vraiment construit misise en œuvre et je
pense que c'est essentiellement sur ces
ressorts là sur ces mécanismes là que
ces catastrophes ont agi puisque on ne
voit pas de de changement spectaculaire
de la réglementation on n pas de
transformation brutale on n pas un texte
qui tout d'un coup est supprimé pour
être remplacé par une écriture toalement
nouvelle non on reste sur les mêmes
bases qui sont fiables qui sont
sérieuses qui prennent en compte les
bons éléments il y a pas d'erreur de de
réglementation il y a une amélioration à
produire sur l'effet terrain l'effet
contrôle et aussi résultat du contrôle
et amélioration de la
sécurité l'incendie de Saint-Laurent du
pont n'aura pas bouleversé les normes
mais plôt la façon dont on vérifie leur
application aujourd'hui les contrôles
sont systématiques et assez
rigoureux proche de la place de la
République le Gibus est une boîte de
nuit et une mythique salle de concert au
petit matin une commission de sécurité
composée d'un architecte d'un
représentant de la préfecture et d'un
pompier vient vérifier le strict respect
des normes de sécurité tous les
établissements recevants du public sont
concernés par ces visites qui peuvent
être prévu à l'avance ou une opiné alors
ce que ce qu'on va vous demander c'est
de basculer sur son alimentation
électrique de sécurité ok je coue
euh et puis ensuite on fera les les
essais alors qu'il est sur sa batterie
ok je vais faire ça
merci donc on a bien deux zones de
désenfumage notre moteur
d'extraction ça serait mieux ici de
mettre des enfumages peties salallle
plutôt que
moteur petre que ce plan il soit un peu
plus une échelle plus grand plus
exp ser bien de mieux visualiser marche
une couleur blanche on VO
[Musique]
pasriarmours fumage extincteur plan
d'évacuation tout est scruté dans les
moindres détails 200000 visites ont lieu
chaque année dans les 600000
établissement recevant du public sur le
territoire fini les responsables
insouciance des années 60 l'État ne
plaisante plus avec la sécurité de ses
administrés les portes
elles servent à
quoi parce qu'on s'en sert des f donc en
fait on ferme mais on ferme ça reste
dans ce CASL enfin lorsque fermé
juste une poignée c'est pas grand chose
plus ferme difficilement si je la pousse
à fond j'ar vous avez une isue de
secours dans cette
salle à la fin de la visite la
commission rédige un procès verbal qui
donne des recommandations et concl sur
un avis favorable ou défavorable à la
poursuite de
l'exploitation question de la sécurité
elle se en TER de coût financier la
commission de sécurité on ne peut pas
transiger sur le niveau de sécurité mais
par contre il faut malgré tout s'assurer
que le le le coût des mesures que nous
demandons est un coût supportable par
l'exploitant globalement aujourd'hui sur
ce qu'on a vu le niveau de sécurité
paraît tout à fait acceptable on a
recané un petit peu la destruction
d'établissement donc on a mis a eu
favorable à la poursuite
d'exploitation
ce genre de commission c'est c'est
important on n'est pas là pour tuer les
gens c'est presque même une récompense
le gérant c'est qu'ici on a des Nmes
quand même justifié mais extrêmement
drastiqu des fois elles sont moyennement
justifié des fois ça un peu de bon sens
mais voilà mais ça c'est pu c'est
rassurant c'est important que le public
soit en sécurité quand il fréquent
l'établissement peut-être qu'il
faudraitussi le que le que la clientèle
se comprenne fasse partie de ce rouage
c'estàd qu'il peutv avoir et
l'exploitant et les commissants de
sécurité les services qui travaillent
entre eux nous notre plus gros problème
par exemple c'est les gens qui comm s'
amuser avec les boîtiers ou les portes
de secours et cetera en attendant bon ça
fait partie du jeu il faudrait peut-être
qu'on puisse avoir des moyens un peu
plus répressifs quand quelqu'un s'amuse
appuyer sur un bouton Utiliser un
mauvais ant parce que ça finit par les
gens du coup sont moins inquiétés c'est
même qu il y a un déclenchement de
sirène curieusement ce déjà arrivé
personne ne bouge
vraiment la sécurité c'est l'affaire de
tous aujourd'hui les normes et les
contrôles sont efficaces et la sécurité
dépend surtout des comportements
individuels dans les lieux publics bien
sûr mais également dans les
habitations au ministère de l'intérieur
on prend la question très au sérieux en
terme de sensibilisation des individus
il reste du travail à
accomplir nous avons des efforts à faire
dans dans les risques de la vie courante
et donc dans le comportement individuel
de chacun leeur de la é il y a eu
l'année dernière près de 800 personnes
décédées dans des incendies en
France un tout petit nombre dans des
établissements recevant du public 5 tous
les autres donc dans des dans des
domiciles dans des résidences et donc
nous avons besoin de de travailler sur
ces événementsl qui sont évidemment une
somme de de d'événements individuel
dramatique c'est par exemple ce qui
vient d'être fait sur les détecteurs
automatiques de fumé euh où il est
évident que c'est à chacun de s'équiper
avec derrière non pas la suppression du
risque incendie mais euh d'autres
conséquences quand l'incendie survient
parce qu'on est réveillé et qu'on a le
temps d'évacuer son domicile et c'est
vrai que cette culture individuelle euh
du du du geste simple du petit
équipement simple euh elle est pas
facile à gérer parce que finalement on a
ancré parfois l'idée que on allait vers
le risque zéro ce qui qui n'existe pas
ou bien que la prise de tel ou telle lo
loi allit régler un problème la loi va
permettre d'accélérer les choses va
permettre d'imposer des obligations mais
ensuite beaucoup dépend des
comportements
[Musique]
individuels la tendance est donc à
responsabiliser les particuliers c'est
peut-être encore une nouvelle air qui
s'ouvre chacun est désormais appelé à
prendre conscience de sa responsabilité
individuelle hasard ou coïncidence ce
glissement a lieu au moment même où les
caises de l'État sont vides l'État qui
se désengage progressivement de toutes
missions régaliennes la sécurité ça
coûte cher et le risque c'est comme le
reste ça peut se privatiser alors chacun
chez soi et Dieu pour
[Musique]
tous c'est un peu comme une bombe des
numéros d'urgence totalement vision
d'apocalypse le nafrage a lieu au large
des côtes de
bretonne une catastrophe écologique de
grande ampleurerçu des de des tonnes
d'eau dévastant l'état de catastrophe
naturelle sera bien déclaré un feu à
traverser environ
50 là c'est une vue qui
[Musique]
sond